a professor of virology and
biotechnology in the department of
pathological sciences and a director of
the division of biotechnology and
molecular medicine
at Louisiana State
LSU biomed Dr collusas has extensively
utilized viral vectors for vaccine
development and cancer treatment his
other research interests lie in the
structure and function of proteins and
glycoprotein and the use of virus-like
particles for drug delivery
bioinformatics and the development of
new drugs to combat infectious diseases
Constantine if you are there the stage
is yours yes good afternoon everybody uh
you know my name is Gus gusudas I'm a
professor of virology and biotechnology
at Louisiana State University and head
of the Department of pathological
Sciences
also the honor of being the president of
the National Association of idea
principal investigators uh nepi nepi is
a uh not-for-profit organization uh that
represents 23 States in Puerto Rico and
all the NIH funding that goes into the
special program from the National
Institute of General Medical Sciences
which is called idea which is really
funding uh biomedical research at
multiple levels
including primarily at The Graduate
institutions
Flagship institutions
clinical translation research centers as
well as a number of other
co-funding opportunities to enter GMS
and I will tell you a little bit about
nebby first and everything else that we
do here but I'm delighted to participate
in this bioinformatics
uh conference we have a long-standing
relationship with pine Bao Tech and we
have embraced the platform and a lot of
the training as well as the software
um and a number of other things that we
do and find Patek is instrumental in
helping our programs here at LSU as well
as through nebby providing uh content
and research opportunities as well as
training modules throughout the 23
States in Puerto Rico so nepi aims to
protect and promote the idea programs as
you'll see later it's approximately 450
million dollars per year allocated to
approximately 200 research centers
throughout the uh the 23 cents of Puerto
Rico it Fosters interactions promotes
resource sharing enhances the visibility
of all these programs that just
mentioned and develops consensus on
priorities identifies and disseminates
best practices and also identifies
opportunities and developing strategies
one of the main
concept is that by promoting biomedical
research Within These 23 States in
Puerto Rico traditionally do not receive
a high level of NIH funding that we be
able to develop Manpower and lift those
states to be able to compete for
traditional NIH funding through all the
categorical NIH Institutes
um this is the uh leadership team
um with uh that uh currently uh you can
see of the nebby website and
um all the programs
um uh fund the organization through a
setup fee and maybe there's a number of
different uh activities uh that I will
mention to you um as we move forward so
the mission again is nappy is to provide
leadership communication and to improve
the biomedical research throughout the
23 States in Puerto Rico we want to
Foster interactions among the idea
programs and all these 23 States in
Puerto Rico to promote uh sharing among
resources among these different programs
and importantly enough that all the
Embrace as well as the cobrasive ctrs
especially the Embry programs have a
special emphasis and mandatory emphasis
on data science and bioinformatics so
one of the major aspects of the Embry
programs the is actually the promoting
data Science and Mathematics I am
currently the principal investigator of
the Louisiana biomedical research
Network
which is one of the import programs
there's only one Embrace per state so
there are 24 of those programs
approximately 20 million over five years
and is devoted to really support
primarily undergraduate institutions
creating a pipeline with a mandatory
activity to be a promoting data Science
and Mathematics so again we're
developing priorities and consensus in
fact we all the Ember apis are meeting
October 18 in New Orleans uh to arrive
at the consensus on priorities and new
directions and we want to identify the
Seminary best practices and to develop
strategies to achieve the common goals
of the entire idea program which is
really a pipeline coming from the
undergraduate to the graduate program to
the postdoc level to The Faculty level
and Beyond
so history of the idea it started in
1993 it was approximately 50 million
over the years has really become a much
bigger approach in one percent of the
NIH funding totally and of course the
program is very unique because it serves
unique populations such as Rural and
medically undeserved communities in
these states so Health disparity is one
of the big thing the topic that's
actually addressed through those States
uh that predominantly have a majority of
these called disparity issues
um this is the after 21 the funding
right now is sits at 2022 at 430 million
hopefully in the next fiscal budget it
will go approaching the 500 million uh
which is will be approximately one
percent of the NIH deposit and of course
a sizable part of every State's funding
is actually uh this idea program as we
see in Louisiana here Mississippi uh you
can see a 20 on million of the 176
million 2021 was actually idea funding
uh the different programs that I
mentioned include the centers for
biomedical resist Excellence the Kobe's
and those are for uh mentored by senior
investigators and their goal is to take
young faculty typically can you track
assistant professors uh to become
independently funded with an R1
mechanism and the program can transit to
a phase two and phase three based on how
successful it is in graduating
independently fund investigators the
idea Network like the Louisiana
biomedical research network has a
different goal of promoting biomedical
research in primarily undergraduate
institutions typically they go for R15
type of Grant applications or by even
beyond that and to create a pipeline of
undergraduate and graduate students that
ultimately feed into coverage and other
programs we also have the clinical
translation research centers that are
sort of a small clinical translational
centers the bigger ones are in
Massachusetts elsewhere those
approximately funded about 20 to 25
million and have a different scope of
really translational medicine
translational research the Pennington
biomedical Center is now the
headquarters of the
louisiana-based clinical translation
center it's called the LA cats
the idea program also provides
co-funding is very important because if
you're a submitting around 115 and you
know within the pay lines you could
actually get funding by having
co-funding provided by the National
Institute of General Medical sciences
and they're also technology transfer
actually the hubs that were funded
previously and they may continue in the
future creating an entrepreneurship
activity to promote also Economic
Development Within These 23 States in
Puerto Rico
um
so
um the uh nigms promotes the additional
programs over the years we had uh
collaborations with other non-idea uh
NIH programs including the maternal and
infant mortality research uh the
covid-19 patient registry cloud
computing
um and affiliation with the United
Stripes program Google and Amazon in
fact they're really discount prices for
idea participants to participate in uh
these particular programs in uh
including Google and Amazon related
products they're also continuing uh uh
new activities in collaboration between
ngms out there once
and I wanted you to look at the ngms
website so actually see these new
initiatives that are subcourse supported
by the idea program and categorical NIH
institutes
um these are the idea States uh in green
here uh that you can see and the
programs include again the Kobe zebri
CTS co-funding and Entrepreneurship hubs
uh the nappy in itself
um has a number of activities and I've
already to look at the nepi.org website
a funds ID undergraduate travel funds to
Washington DC to visit Congress it
Awards uh undergraduate graduate
students and assistant professors best
presentations we have four Regional idea
meetings in four of those uh regions
that nngms has you know be able to
enlist us and we also have a national
meeting the national uh idea Symposium
biomedical assets Excellence on misery
that was held every other year in
Washington DC uh in person
um those were basically postponed
because of covid-19 the next virtual
conference would be held December 12th
through 14 uh it would be from noon to 6
pm to accommodate the different time
zones lunch and we hope to make these
announcements and start accepting
abstracts and all presentations uh very
soon uh we also uh will be through the
nappy you'll be able to access a DIY
databases and it says expertise and
network with other investigators and we
have offered oops
discounts to Virtual courses data
science and diplomatics in a
collaboration with the pine biotech that
you see on the nepi website
a number of activities included nappy
sponsors Symposium this was a 2020 on
Symposium other Symposium have also been
promoted to the Navy including I think
this one here this conference I hope
it's also on the nepi website
and the last thing I wanted to talk to
you about is the Louisiana biomedical
research network uh this is the website
for the uh Network itself and
um you can see through that and level of
information about louisiana-specific
activities
um we do we have a summer program that
is also funded by the Louisiana border
regions we had over 50 to 70 people
participating in different projects of
the summer related to bipomatics and
computational biology that we execute
every summer and of course the lbrn has
two major cores one is the bipomatics
Inc by computation core which is headed
by Dr Chris Taylor who's a professor at
the LSU Health Science Center in New
Orleans and a protein production
purification proteomics libidomic score
that's uh headed by Dr Johan Lee was a
professor here at the LSU campus in the
department of biological sciences
the lbrn has an annual meeting that's
scheduled for uh most likely the second
week of January and we do uh invite uh
people from all over Louisiana to
participate especially people that are
funded or participate in active or DRM
programs but others can actually visit
we also sponsor a bioinformatics
Regional Conference and that will be
planned uh hopefully in New Orleans at
the University of New Orleans campus
sometime next April through our lbra
website you'll be able to see recorded
lectures or previous bioinformatics
conferences we had one last year which
was virtual they had 10 uh fantastic
speakers from all over the country
included Michael Snyder the chairman of
the popular genetics at Stanford
um promoting this composite of
uh uh transcriptomics proteomics
metabolomics totally arrive at the
digital twin that would enable to
predict diseases and follow patterns uh
changes in the body uh in in addition to
a complete scan
um you know head to toe
that provides new information of
um how basically everything works and
integrating this data into a digital
twin because I think a fantastic
presentation and that's where basically
ultimately the science of data Science
and Mathematics will go especially for
health you know where you'll be able to
combine huge data sets where that would
be
genomics transcriptomics proteomics
metabolomics health related factors in
clinical readings
to be able to combine all those to
create a digital twin that ultimately
would predict or basically
detect any potential perturbations in
the body system to allow for
prophylactic or therapeutic approaches
to disease that may occur much later in
life so
this is what I wanted to sort of
formally discuss with you and I'll be
happy in the remainder time to answer
any questions that you may have with
regard to NIH the idea program nepi lbrn
or any other topic in bioinformatics I
had the pleasure working with pine
biotech to offer an advanced course in
transcriptomics a few years ago
we are now promoting the creation of the
bioinformatics data science mathematics
course in every uh primarily
undergraduate institution
in Louisiana those are eight
institutions in that are primary
institutions
however there are 27 that participate
throughout the state Louisiana so we
hope to start with LSU uh three report
to create uh with Dr Vasquez Beck a
bioinformatics course at the 4000 level
for undergraduates and graduates and
that will be using content from buying
bot Tech as well as faculty members from
the network and we hope to repeat that
and create a data science biplomatics
course in every of the eight uh
principle primarily at The Graduate
institutions and this is really the
purpose of lbrn and the idea program to
provide opportunities and training uh
for biomedical research with a special
emphasis in data science and
bioinformatics so um I'll stop sharing
and uh I'll be happy to answer any
questions
thank you uh wonderful all this all this
help uh we just went through the poster
presentations and the awards and to have
this much help out there it's wonderful
so uh how is nepi working with the idea
Community to promote biomedical research
training and Advance the importance of
all the nepe programs
so um nappy is the
principle or core principle organizer of
the national newsbre meeting and also
participates in all the regional
meetings
um all the registrations and some of the
expenses already picked up on Epi uh
however LSU has a um U13 Grant to
support the conference so it's actually
an NIH LSU nappy collaboration to run
those major uh conferences and we
provide stipends on our area for
bioinformatics speakers and we organize
symposia within those conferences for
biomatics the other important thing that
really has started is to provide uh
subsidized or discounted courses
trainings we started with buying biotech
to throughout the network
also we have asked content
that is being created by any of these
these programs 200 programs uh whether
that would be special projects or
exercises or even you know a recorded
um uh training uh that can be uploaded
on the nappy website and shared among
all these individuals
um we'd like to also to ultimately
create a forum for job Seekers and
placement of graduate students
um especially in the data science
mathematics sector and you know we're
moving towards this goal as we try to
populate the website more than we have
at this point
I I don't think I can hear you for some
reason you got muted
ah yes I wonder who clicked my mic
button that's probably me
um this is from the chat
um this is specific to African students
but you may want to answer more
generally are there internships or
workshops that are fully funded for
students regarding bioinformatics uh
gwas and transcriptnonics data analysis
possibly specifically any any of that
so obviously
um you know through these programs all
the inbred programs have fellowships and
support students but really you know
they're limited to those State
um participants uh so for instance the
Puerto Rico embryo who support Puerto
Rico Louisiana will support Louisiana
through the brn and so on
um at this point we don't have
fellowships for international
uh students to participate
um in particular programs unless the
incoming students to any of the
participating institutions here in the
US however it is possible through
philanthropic donations to uh nappy and
we've had some fun before that that
could be something that we could work in
the long run
very good and in relation
um the the backside team helped me out
with a career opportunities link on the
nepe website so that was posted to chat
for those of you that are interested in
so we've got that link up there also so
make sure you check out the chat box so
how can all these programs from the
whole program work together more
efficiently is there a way to do that
well this is why uh the Embry uh uh
programs
um which I really
um for uh uh
all of them including the principal
investigators and the coordinators are
meeting in New Orleans October 18 in a
whole day meeting to actually find ways
that we could communicate better
together there's already
um uh annual meetings with the principal
investigators are meeting to discuss
potential collaborations we do
participate in Regional meetings because
again five or six states have their own
original meetings so we all get together
and discuss different things they
haven't been formal ways to actually get
programs to work together part of the
difficulty is because the funding is
limited to uh individual states so we
cannot use Louisiana funding to send our
students easily to another state and the
vice versa so it has to be
self-government exchange well you know
somehow we'll be able to do this and
some of that has been occurring already
so we can send students for instance to
the Mississippi proteomic training
courses but if you look at the Navy
website and you look at all these
programs it's pretty amazing the amount
of resources for biomedical research
that they have and and um uh NIH is
really promoting this Synergy and
collaboration
I think we started doing this but
obviously we could do much better
so we've we've posted two links now one
of the uh omixlogic website and and nepi
so what are opportunities for students
pursuing data science or other Amex
studies at nepe and are there formal
certificate courses that can be obtained
do they have to go for please talk into
that please
yeah one of the discussions uh has been
uh whether uh individual programs where
there would be lbrn for Louisiana
creates a certificate program uh the
difficulty there is that we have
multiple institutions uh in order to
actually get students enrolled and
receive credit uh a particular program
has to be accepted by all campuses so
the alternative to this is to actually
help thrill brn and maybe nepi to have
uh courses in individual campuses that
are supported through nappy or lbrn I do
a division of all the possibility of
having an epi-specific certificate uh or
a
um uh State specific certificate uh
however that certificate would be an
epic certificate not necessarily a full
credit certificate that the typical
higher education institution will give
and
um the enrollment for this uh would be
hopefully partially supported by
philanthropic donations as well as
registration uh that would be paid
individually hopefully at the minimum
cost to have as wide participation as
possible
did the universities recognize the nepi
certificates as access to other programs
or like almost like gained hours that
they don't have to get later
um they do not right now because you
know most institutions keep very close
control of their credit hours however
um obviously this certificates do count
for the job market as well as
potentially for incoming graduate
students or Preparation Advanced
preparation so they could actually meet
expectations when they get into a
regular credit-oriented curriculum
um I I know little about these
certificate courses and I'm sure they
may vary but is there a is there a time
can person get a certificate in eight
weeks is it eight months can you speak
to that
well we are really at the planning stage
right now and um uh the anticipation is
that there would be a very specific
program where you'll be getting uh
different levels of certification
um by providing a variety of different
um modules that will start from very
basic going to very Advanced and
um the certificate could be awarded at
the different levels level one level two
level three
um you know whether you know be the
experts certificate that type of thing
um so uh that's something that we have
been you know discussing and we hope to
launch
um maybe at the beginning of next year
after we get um you know everything that
we need to do
um uh establish already so we can
actually pilot it uh first and then move
it to heavy the Bonafide program
so what I hear you saying is someone
might be able to go a short shorter
period of time and get a lower level
certificate but then build on that build
on that and build on that possibly swear
yeah exactly and I think you know buying
about tech has a lot of content right
now we work maybe works very closely
with uh buying biotech
um like I said we hope to get some
philanthropy donations to be able to
allow people to register at the lower
cost through dampy and then use the
nappy credentials to validate you know
those certificates at that level because
don't forget they're really practically
um a hundred institutions of Higher
Learning in 24 states that are basically
support nappy at this point
fascinating so we already talked about
internships and job opportunities
but what can a student do after they
complete a training or get a certificate
where can they find research or or
things to bite into any other questions
on the level of the student
um obviously if you're undergraduate
then you uh seeking to go to graduate
school that becomes very important
because you hit the ground running and
you know a lot of different things and
it depends if you go in engineering or
in bioinformatics or data science you'll
be able to really just go through that
curriculum very easily obviously uh in
the uh in Industry right now anybody
that is has credentials in data science
specifically but by informatics in
general uh sold out and
um and that creates a lot of job
opportunities in the clinical uh setting
as well as on the research Enterprises
will be biotech startups and so on so it
depends you know the ultimately this is
a data science intensive environment I
think anybody that works in data science
and bioinformatics uh depending on the
field itself
could secure probably a very bright
future
either in the higher education academic
setting or in industry
fascinating well thank you yet again
we're going to go ahead and release you
to the rest of your day and we thank you
for being here we appreciate all the
input on nepe and all that you're
involved in and uh again just thank you
so much and uh we will hopefully see you
again thank you sir okay thanks uh Grant
and then anybody that may have some
questions please uh you know contact
other nappy directly to the contact
information oral brn
um the Louisiana biomedical Resource
Network okay have a great day bye now
thank you